ben jeis enfin une définition simple je
dirais que c'est simplement un l'usage
de drogue en contexte sexuel donc il y a
plusieurs contextes d'usage ça peut être
festif euh et c'est quoi en fait c'est
quoi comme drogue alors c'est c'est vrai
qu'il y a il y a des produits un peu
plus un peu spécifiques on va dire à la
culture sexuelle gay dans dans laquelle
est né le chemsexe he puisque ça fait 10
12 ans qu'on qu' qu'on parle d'un
phénomène chemsex moi je pense que c'est
aussi lié à une culture sexuelle euh et
effectivement il y a des produits qui
sont plutôt
comment dire lié à cette culture donc je
pense à au catinon je pense au cristal
on sait pas de quoi vous parlez là bah
parf parle de la 3 en langage plus
courant non pas d'autoroute non
mais c'est en voilà il y a différents
noms pour différents produits on parle
beaucoup du GHB aussi par exemple qui
peut être aussi utilisé en contexte
sexuel voilà enfin par exemple c'est
quoi ces soirées parce queil paraît que
ça peut durer des heures et des heur
Maron du sexe en fait ça peut être ça
peut être ça mais ça ça dépend il y a
toutes sortes de situation on veut
savoir faites quoi là qu'est-ce que je
fais sexuellement
parlant mais pour les hommes ça permet
d'avoir la Gaule plus long c'est bon
c'est bon
merciasterx alors ça dépend vraiment du
produit pour le coup hein et et je pense
que c'est pas tant une question
d'érection c'est plutôt une question de
de des des inhibitions
de comment dire vous faites des soirées
comme ça vous encore oui ça mais c'est
quoi comment on s'appelle on dit ouais
on va se droguer on va si vous voulez
par exemple dans la culture htéro les
gens ils vont boire un verre de vin il
vont éventuellement fumer un pétard bah
nous on va se faire une ligne de TR par
exemple je rappelle que l'ABU d'alcool
est dangere santé aussi laab de drogue
aussi et vous vous faites ça comme ça
tranquille bah écoutez moi je pense
qu'il faut pas stigmatiser l'usage de
drogue je pense
que vous dites ça maintenant on en
reparlera dans quelques années vous
allez voir vous AZ vu ce qui est arriv à
Pierre Palmade justement justement
justement parce que je pense que c c'est
à cause de la prohibition
stigmatisation qu'on arrive à
déresponsabiliser ensuite les
comportements parce que pour l'alcool
pour l'alcool justement il y a des
campagnes de prévention il y a des
messages de prévention par rapport au
fait de pas conduire sous état sous sous
emprise d'un produit pour quand il
s'agit des autres produits qui sont
illégaux on n pas ce ce ce discours sur
le bon usage sur les la réduction des
risques ça c'est c'est ça dont on a
besoin et après après voilà prendre la
voiture et mettre en danger la vie
d'autruille festive vous preniez
certains produits mais là dans kemsex
métamphétamine kétamine cocaïne mais
c'est quoi là on dirait quea mais c'est
des produits qu'on prend pour se
stimuler et ces produits là sont
totalement illégaux c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas des produits qu'on peut
prendre dans un cas de festif c'est oui
mais c'est pas du Cacolac quoi bah pas
du tout c'est illégal donc monsieur vous
pouvez pas faire l'apologie de la prise
de
drogie je fais aucune apologie faut
arrêter de stigmatiser l'usage de drogue
parce que on arrive avec des situations
et des drames comme celui-là où on
déresponsabilise les gens en fait c'està
dire que moi je pense que si on va avoir
une approche de réduction des risques
qui soit efficace il faut arrêter avec
les condamnations moral parce que là on
a des personnes comme enfin moi je suis
pas là pour défendre monsieur palman en
particulier mais ça fait des années des
années que les gens savent qu'il a des
problèmes de consommation c'est
quelqu'un qui est complètement isolé sur
ce problème là personne va l'aider
apparemment on arrive à ce genre de
situation là moi je pense que quand on
quand les gens se disent bon interdit
pour interdit du coup ils font n'importe
quoi effectivement au près une voiture
alors que si on avait un message clair
par exemple sur l'alcool c'est un
produit qui est très dangereux en
réalité l'alcool mais on a une culture
d'usage de l'alcool c'estàdire qu'on
sait par exemple comment doser il y a
des ver différents selon message clair
c'est quand on boit on ne conduit pas
quand on de la drogue on ne conduit pas
on risque de mettre en danger la
aujourd'hui ces messages là n'existent
pas parce que le seul message qui existe
c'est c'est de la merde c'est pas bien
nanana et donc on est juste dans une
condamnation morale on cherche pas à à
comprendre les gens et à essayer
justement de les responsabiliser par
rapport à leur comportement alors il
paraît même sur des applications on vous
propose des soirées
but des emes ouiopie oui y il y a un
bouquin que j'ai lu il y a quelques
temps de Johann Zarka qui en parle très
bien qui s'appelle donc Kem sex et qui
parle de ça de ses pratiques sexuelles
et c'est en
fait cet auteur justement il raconte un
peu les bafons Parisiens et C les nuits
parisiennes et entre autres les soirées
kemsex auquell il a participé et en fait
il y a quand même beaucoup de soirées je
sais pas si vous avez assisté à ce genre
de chos mais au domicile par exemp de
certaines personnes et en fait elles
sont souvent filmées souvent à plusieurs
et souvent en fait la pièce dans
laquelle ça se passe c'est bâché en fait
donc il se passe des trucs très très
trashes ouais bâé avec des bâes en
plastique pour voilà pour éviter les non
c'est
trashime donc il y a c'est que des en
fait c'est que des molécules chimiques
qui sont mélangées les unes aux autres
vous m'arrêtez hein si je dis n'importe
quoi mais enfin en tout cas c'est ce qui
raconé dans le Bouen moi je les ai pas
vécu mais lui il les a vécu et il les
relate dans ce livre et et voilà c'est
des molécules chimiques sur molécules
chimiques c'est que des mélanges ça peut
durer parfois des heures ou des jours
entiers et c'est trashissime quoi en
fait on fait pas ça par hasard vous
faites pas ça juste pour faire durer le
plaisir plus longtemps parce que il
explique en plus que non seulement enfin
oui on bande pendant des heures et
cetera c'est bon c'est bon ça se dilate
de partout et en plus de ça il y a pas
d'orgasme c'est enfin l'orgasme est
retardé s' fout ça on va pas rentrer
dans les détails B vous me demande
décrire les soir on dit que les gens qui
pratiquent le cemsex sont souvent des
gens qui ont du mal à assumer leur
sexualité donc parfois des ét qui se
cachent à eux-même qui sont homosexuels
ou des gens qui aiment certaines
pratiques mais qui ont besoin d'être
dans un état second pour les les les
pratiquer justement est-ce que c'est
vrai ouis euh je ne pense pas ENF moi je
pense que il faut éviter de généraliser
là parce que là j'entends plein de
choses et en fait je pense qu'il y a
tout types de situations qui existent en
réalité je pense qu'il y a aussi des
hétérosexuels qui consomment des drogues
en contexte sexuel sauf que on n pas
utilisé de de terme pour ça et que moi
j'ai l'impression queon est en train de
fantasmer de faire des projections sur
la vie sexuelle des gens mais en fait en
fait c'est quelque chose ENF l'usage de
drog ça existe depuis la nuit des temps
en fait on va on on a la chance d'avoir
une n CLOB ici Daniel non mais mais je
peux enfin on peut pas laisser dire ça
c'est le Washington Post a dit que quand
même le kemsex c'est le sida numéro 2
c'est très très
dangerux de comparer avec le sida là
parceil y a le sida c'est quand même une
histoire très traumatisante pour notre
communauté invite réfléchir quand même
en disant ça c'est très dangereux pour
les participants aussi là
malheureusement France a été quand même
excusez-moi ende le mari de Jean-Luc
Romero qui est conseiller de Paris hein
est mort pendant une un quemsex parce
que en plus évidemment quand il y a un
gros problème ces gens-là n'osent pas
appeler peut-être la police soit par r
soit par peur donc ils peuvent mourir
sur place c'est ce qui est arrivé au
mari de Jean-Luc romiro donc quand vous
nous expliquez qu'il faut pas
stigmatiser je ne sais quoi c'est des
jolis mots mais voilà la réalité c'est
ça et la les gens sont très inquiets sur
ce phénomène qui prend l'ampleur qui
était hétéro pardon homo au départ qui
est né en en Grande-Bretagne mais qui
était très encadré parce que justement
on connaît les dangers de ces pratiques
là maintenant c'est vraiment n'importe
quand n'importe n'importe où avec
n'importe qui ça ça ça gagne sur les
htéro et c'est très très inquiétant
c'est pH voilàprès stigmatiser ou pas
stigmatiser are chose je vrais r ce que
V dire parce quand vous dites les
personnes se sont
enfuies dans ce dans ce contexte là
parce qu'ils ont paniqué moi je pense
que c'est le résultat d'un contexte
actuel qui est le contexte de la
prohibition parce qu'effectivement les
gens ils paniquent parce qu'ils ont peur
parce qu'ils se disent si j'appelle les
SAMU ou quoi que ce soit il y a les F
qui vont débarquer je vais risquer je
suis fait nimporte quoi g nimporte quoi
parce que on est dans ce contexte
là Dr
est à cause de la
prohibition non j'ai dit que c'est à
cause de la prohibition que les gens
paniquent et au li d'apper si mais vous
monsieur pas
dire mais oui c'est laist on est
d'accord mais pourquoi parce que les
gens ne ne ne peuvent pas en fait la
prohibition bien sû c'est à cause de la
prohibition non moi ce que je veux dire
est ce qui m'intéresse dans ce que ce
garçon a dit c'est c'est une autre
génération la mienne c'était de l'alcool
dans les soirées tout ça ça n'existait
pas tout ça ce qui est intéressant ce
que vous dites c'est que oui on connaît
pas quand tu dis effectivement tu bois
de l'alcool tu sais les effets et donc
tu sais pourquoi tu doas pas boire tu
prends une drogue que tu as dit qui
étaitamine personne sait ce que c'est
donc unom qui prend ça peut-être qu'il
sait pas que derrière il peut pas
conduire donc je pense que il
faut non je pense qu'il faut au moins
informer aujourd'hui les gens sur ces
dangers sur ces choses parce que là on
parle de choses personne sait ce que
c'est personne sait rien donc les
mots Mo je parle des
soir pas de B en a plein font des soiré
mais c'est pour ça que vous avez une
responsabilité dans ce que vous dites
pardon pardonnez-moi on regardé beaucoup
de jeunes et en terme de service
aprèsvente pardon mais le chemsex malgré
tout c'est très très risqué il faut que
vous le disiez en fait à ceux qui nous
regardent parce que vous vous le
pratiquez c'est très risqué il y a une
explosion de l'hépatite C à cause des
risques à cause des PL à cause des absè
il y a une explosion des cas de VIH
c'est c'est c'est dans toutes les les
les publications aujourd'hui à San
Francisco et tout ça donc peut dire que
c'est très très très dangereux c'est pas
anodin c'est pas banal c'est pas drôle
si vous voulez avoir une action de santé
eff
et que les personnes vous écoutent je
pense qu'il vaut mieux éviter d'être
dans une condamation morale mais plutôt
justement écouter le ce qu'ilst ce que
les personnes ont à dire dans leurs
pratique dans leurs
usagesation morale monsieur très bien
dire que c'est extrê dangux on on va
passer merci l'alcool c'est extrêmement
dangereux et je suis pas en train de de
vous de dire vous les htux vous êtes
vraiment des vraiment des irresponsables
à boire de l'alcool et à vous tuer sur
la route ça fait des milliers de morts
sur la route ch
anné la seule différence c'est qu' il y
en a un qui est légal et l'autre qui est
illégalou c'est tout j'ai remarqué que
tous les gens qui s'assoient là-bas ils
sont
[Rires]
énervés y a peut-être une raison en fait
merci en tout cas d'avoir été là etir
témoigné à visage découvert en tout
cas